There are a series of bills popping up in
a bunch of states that would criminalize and
repress protests of all types.
And this is really chilling.
Red alert, authoritarian type stuff.
In Nashville, Tennessee, lawmakers have put
together a bill eight thousand five eight
zero zero five, that Senate bill and House
Bill eight zero zero five already passed.
The legislature would make it a class E felony
to camp on state public or a state or public
property between 10:00 p.m. and 7:00 a.m..
Now, what's the idea there?
The idea is have carte blanche, have a blank
slate to go after protests that will occupy
a plaza for some time or a park for some time.
Once 10:00 p.m. comes classi felony.
Start arresting everybody.
They are threatening convictions punishable
by up to six years in prison and the possible
loss of your voting rights.
It makes it easier to charge protesters with
theft if they mark up state buildings with
chalk.
A Michigan bill will classify rioting as terrorism.
Now, what's the problem there?
The line on rioting is in and of itself up
for debate.
This would make anything that you can call
rioting, even if it's not terrorism.
It would make acts of, quote, social and domestic
anarchy punishable by up to 20 years in prison
or a 250000 dollar fine in South Dakota.
The governor signed into law stricter penalties
for rioting and inciting a riot.
Now, inciting a riot is pernicious since animated
protesting could conceivably look like it
incited someone to start rioting.
And that's a really broad catchall that is
being applied there in Louisiana.
There's a bill on the table which could mean
15 years in prison for protesting, quote,
on critical infrastructure.
What's the idea there to repress protests
near a pipeline that residents in Louisiana
oppose?
Now, there are many more examples.
More than 20 states over the last couple of
years have proposed some of these types of
bills.
The idea is sometimes to criminalize homelessness.
Sometimes it's to criminalize protesting.
Other times it's to restrict, restrict speech
in practice, although they claim that's not
what they're doing in theory.
And this is the stuff that reminds us why
we need to vote at every level.
It's not just presidential, but we need state
senates, state legislatures, governorships,
because those are the origins of a lot of
these bills.
And those are people choosing many of the
state judges that might eventually decide
on the legality of some of these authoritarian
restrictions on protesting.
Authoritarianism really does not like protesting.
We know that from history now.
I think it's also important to remember that
this is not just about new laws.
You can weaponize existing laws as well, which
is why we need the right mayors and police
chiefs in place.
Mayors often choosing police chiefs because
they can take advantage of existing curfew
laws.
They can focus on unlawful assembly angles,
on gatherings.
And on and on, so it's not just about state
legislatures, state senators and governors,
we need the right mayors.
We need to push them to select the right police
chiefs.
This is much more than the presidency.
By the way, it's also really weird and of
course, completely hypocritical that many
of the same people stockpiling weapons in
case the government were to become tyrannical
are in support of laws cracking down on unarmed
protesters.
On our saying, well, if the gatherings are
against the law, these protesters should find
some other way to request redress of their
grievances.
What's what?
Things are completely backwards, of course.
And this is just the latest.